quick to the bat cave Dr bright cried
reaching for his utility belt but there
was no time he couldn't get his hand on
his grappling hook before the guard
tackled him to the ground but how did we
get here how did Dr bright wind up
apprehended by the red right hand while
dressed in a Halloween store Batman
costume well it's a long story but it
all started a few weeks ago you see Dr
Wright was watching Justice League no
not that one no not that one either he
was watching the animated series from
2001. he loved Superhero Cartoons and
always had since he was a little kid of
course he could barely remember his
childhood a lot of the times these days
he wondered if that was a side effect of
changing bodies so many times if his
memories were fading with each new host
he took but then he shook off the
thought and immersed himself in a world
of brightly colored costumes impossible
Feats of heroism and Adventures in the
fight against evil and Injustice things
were simple here things were safe if
only his life could be like that if he
could be some kind of Superhero fighting
alongside a crew of other special
individuals dedicated to high-minded
ideals like truth justice and a better
world for all but why couldn't his life
be like that what was stopping him from
forming a Justice League of his very own
he was sad lonely and had no contact
with his immediate family he had tons of
resources at his disposal even if most
of those resources didn't technically
belong to him when he thought about it
there wasn't much difference between him
and Batman all he needed was a costume
and a team and he already had last
Halloween's outfit ready to go in his
closet but before he could recruit the
rest of his SCP Foundation Justice
League Dr bright needed one more thing
that Batman had and he didn't a butler
fortunately he knew he exactly where to
find one he retrieved scp-662 from its
storage locker and shook it producing a
soft chime immediately Mr Deeds appeared
ready to attend to any task at hand good
afternoon Dr bright how may I be of
service the butler asked well Mr Deeds
you're going to help me build the team
if Dr bright was Batman then the first
thing he needed to do was identify his
Superman who could be the man of steel
to his Caped Crusader there was one
obvious answer really a man with metal
arms and legs who could withstand any
damage done to him it would have to be
scp-073 Kane while Mr Dietz was pitching
Kane on the idea Dr bright got to work
on brainstorming his next pick he needed
someone with reality warping Powers
someone who could make objects appear
out of thin air teleport from one place
to another there was no one he knew who
could do that better than God himself
scp-343 when presented with the chance
to do battle against the forces of evil
he was more than willing to join the
team while Dr bright was trying to
decide on his next chosen teammate he
received an unexpected visitor cactus
man stopped by the Hall of Justice also
known as Dr Bright's office and begged
to be given a place in the league he
wasn't exactly a martian or a Manhunter
but this was Dr Bright's own unique spin
on the old formula so it couldn't hurt
to deviate just a little bit besides
cactus man looked so sad when he asked
to join in and he couldn't say no to
that face of course Dr bright wasn't
about to forget his second favorite
superhero just behind Batman he needed a
Wonder Woman but who could compare to a
super powerful Amazon from an all-female
island there wasn't anyone with the
lasso of truth but he did know a
perfectly sweet candidate she wouldn't
be too thrilled to work with a man but
when he offered to swap her nasty sugar
substitute meals for the real thing Miss
sweetie was perfectly delighted to join
in he had dominion over land covered but
Dr bright supposed he needed someone who
could handle more aquatic missions an
Adept swimmer perhaps with the ability
to talk to fish even command them he
knew just the guy to talk to you've got
the wrong idea pal Mr Fish side I don't
have any special powers I'm just a guy
from Bastin with a fish head that's my
whole bag sorry fortunately Dr bright
had a backup so with Mr Fish refusing to
take part he turned to a second choice
scp-054 who better to help with
water-based conflicts than someone made
entirely Out of Water herself the final
member of the team was scp-2094 motor
mouth to be completely honest Dr
Brighton mainly picked him because he
was funny and because his name already
kind of sounded like the name of a
superhero was it shallow yes did Dr
bright care absolutely not Dr bright was
so occupied with the task of forming his
League of Heroes that he didn't stop to
consider that every Force for good needs
an equal opposite just as you cannot
have light without Darkness it is also
true that every hero needs a villain
enter Dr Alto cleff as the day went on
Dr clef had caught wind of his
colleague's little plan and decided not
to let Dr bright have all the fun he was
forming a team of his own a Legion of
Doom every bit as powerful with a taste
formed mischief and destruction he
fancied himself the SCP foundation's
very own Lex Luthor a Dapper genius with
the necessary power and Leadership
skills to run an eventual evil empire
after all hidari worked for the GOC
before working with the foundation maybe
he should try his hand at being his own
diabolical boss for once he would be the
brains of the operation to be sure but
he would need some muscle to back him up
someone to help physically intimidate
any foes to crush obstacles that might
stand in his way
scp-076-2 the immortal Warrior no known
as able would do nicely his superhuman
strength speed and resilience to pain
and shock made for the perfect guy to
call on if the boss needed a steel door
ripped off its hinges or someone to
punch through a concrete wall Dr klaff
had him flown in and once Abel was
presented with the promise of as much
violence as his bloodthirsty heart
desired he was thrilled to call himself
a member of the SCP Legion of Doom just
as it had with Dr Bright's plan word of
Dr clef's nefarious scheme began to
spread like wildfire naturally he began
to attract some volunteers that was to
be expected what Dr clef did not expect
however was the site of
scp-082 straining the seams of a purple
suit with his enormous stature a vivid
green wig perched on the top of his head
his face was smeared with makeup the
white base paint of a clown and a wide
garish red mouth do you want to know how
I got these scars he asked for the wild
cackle nice costume Dr cleff nodded
approvingly what costume Fernand replied
it is me I'm the Joker I finished
destroying Gotham City like I wanted to
all done with that so now I'm looking
for a new job want to see a magic trick
he pulled a pencil out of his pocket and
Dr clef snatched it out of his hand not
right now but come on in let's make a
little Mayhem one of Dr clef's favorite
villains of all time was Two-Face a
formerly good man fallen from Grace
transformed into a capricious monster
deciding a victim's fate with the toss
of a coin he didn't know anyone with two
faces at the foundation but he did know
of one anomaly that was capable of
having any face in the world as long as
it was beautiful
bit of flattery was enough to win over
scp-056 though they still made it clear
they were joining out of the kindness of
their heart I'm far too good for this
nonsense but I'm bored so I'll give it a
try anyway next Dr clef supplied the
meanest mask around
scp-035 the possessive mask with a
special treat a temporary body in the
form of a life-size action figure of the
Riddler know any good riddles he asked
as he placed the mask over the figure's
plastic face it grinned at him black
slime dripping from its open mouth the
person who built it sold it the person
who bought it never used it the person
who used it never saw it what is it Dr
clef Shrugged final hint anyone who
opposes me will end up inside of one the
mask's smile seemed to widen Dr clef
laughs suddenly as the answer occurred
to him a coffin this was going to be fun
wanting a man with the knowledge of
Medical Science on his side not to
mention a touch that could stop a heart
instantly Dr cleff attempted to recruit
the plague doctor but he wouldn't accept
the offer insisting he had far too much
work to attend to and he would never
want to join a team that quote The
Infernal mask was part of in the first
place with both groups assembled the SCP
Justice League and the SCP Legion of
Doom there was only one thing left to do
let the two sides battle it out and see
just who would Triumph in the end as Dr
bright sat at the head of the table in
his Hall of SCP Justice preparing to
begin the first official meeting of his
super team a rock crashed through the
window of the room wrapped around it was
a note made from letters cut out of
magazines and pasted onto paper to form
new words come out and play a direct
Challenge from his new arch nemesis no
doubt the there was no time to waste the
team had to suit up and prepare to face
off against the forces of evil Dr bright
pulled on his Batman costume silently
cursing himself for not springing for
the real drivable Batmobile when he had
the chance but now was not the time for
bat regrets now was the time for Action
Mr Deeds he rang the bell yes sir the
butler appeared please fetch the rest of
the team their uniforms within moments
they were dressed for action in the
Technicolor attire of bona fide
superheroes sure some costumes were too
small others were too large and Cactus
man spikes kept poking holes in the
spandex but Dr bright thought they all
looked perfect the SCP Justice League
burst into the SCP Legion of Doom's
headquarters formerly known as the
canteen where they found Dr clef and his
army of bad East waiting riddle me this
the mask called out the boar have it the
rich need it if you eat it you die and
it is the only thing that can stop me
why what is it oh I know the answer
Fernand piped up it is nothing well
aren't you clever a beautiful person
snarked I was promised I would get to do
some stabbing able ground ready to give
up now bright Dr clef asked never Dr
Brian cried and what was perhaps the
most bizarre Petty and unnecessary
battle between a pair of man children
and their homegrown super squads began
Dr bright and Dr clef themselves were of
course at the front lines engaging in a
somewhat embarrassing bare knuckle Brawl
on the dirty tile floor nearby their
violent Army began duking it out on
their behalf Ferdinand still dressed as
the Joker began duking it out with Kane
who tried to encourage the giant
cannibal to take a non-violent route
Ferdinand true to his diabolical costume
Spirit didn't listen to reason and
instead tried to bite Kane this was a
terrible move as Fernand quickly
realized when his own bite marks began
appearing on the fabric of his cheap
purple suit that did not stop him from
trying again and again and again next
came the obligatory superhero movie
cliche of the two token female supers
pairing off to fight each other in the
way that feels oddly condescending
scp-056 was duking it out with the water
nymph and Miss sweetie whose diabolical
ability to make others feel terrible
about themselves through Relentless one
upsmanship was being blunted by the
water nymph and Miss sweetie bolstering
each other's self-esteem with
compliments and mutual emotional support
eventually this frustrated scp-056 so
much so that she got frustrated and
stormed away like the unpleasant
entitled bully she is meanwhile despite
the fact that cactus man was fighting
valiantly the evil powers of scp-035
were too much for him the mask was
wrapping its stolen hands around Cactus
man's thorny throat and squeezing slowly
making it harder for him to breathe the
mass gave an evil cackle and said silly
little boy playing hero what a waste of
a life don't worry boy as one of my
hosts you'll finally be part of
something worthwhile I'll Never Give In
To You villain cactus man chokes out you
don't have a choice my boy we always
have a choice said a calm fatherly voice
the voice of scp-343 with a flick of his
immensely powerful wrist 035 was sent
sailing across the room whacking him
against the wall his melting host body
splattered from the impact and the mass
cluttered down to the ground
The Mask yelled filed again Abel was
having an extremely frustrating battle
with motor mouth he produced a plethora
of obsidian blades from his pocket
Dimension and began tossing them at the
anomalous Carney at incredible speeds
however Abel was not aware that in
addition to motor Mouse ability to
stretch his jaw and shamelessly swallow
anything his time with Hermann Fuller's
circus of the disquieting had also made
him an expert juggler he was able to
catch each of Abel's blades and swallow
them effortlessly stop doing that they
both fumed it is dishonorable with chaos
unfolding all around them Dr Bryant and
Dr klaff stopped fighting to take in the
Majesty of their co-created travesty
scps kicking the tar out of each other
all over the site-19 canteen it was
truly something to behold and certainly
a fun way to kill an afternoon you know
Dr clef locked eyes with Dr bright We're
Not So Different you and I but before he
could finish the rest of his truly epic
speech an armed guard kicked down the
door and the members of MTF alpha 1 the
red right hand began pouring into the
room they tackled Dr Wright and Dr cleft
the ground and set about neutralizing
any other threats in the room some
anomalies returned to their containment
Chambers willingly like Ferdinand
sprinting down the hall at a
surprisingly fast pace and insisting it
was peer pressure you see I never wanted
to others like Abel refused to go back
down slashing his sword wildly and
taking out a dozen guards before he was
recontained so we find ourselves back to
where we started with a whim in the
shape of the bat signal with a moment of
great Triumph followed by a swift
descent into failure and a mobile Task
Force member putting Dr cleff in
handcuffs luckily the two doctors
wouldn't be thrown into Arkham for
letting their imagination get the better
of them though their egos and bodies
were a bit bruised they would be free to
fight another day 05-1 the
long-suffering chairman of the o5
council released a memo regarding the
matter which was delivered to both Dr
bright and Dr clef during their
disciplinary hearings we'll allow that
memo to play us out I wish I could say I
was surprised did your mother's not hug
you enough as children did people not
pay enough attention to you jack Alto to
the best of my knowledge you are a pair
of grown bloody men working for the most
powerful and vital anti-anomely
organization in the world where you
terrifyingly have positions of
considerable influence act like it and
please know that if I catch wind of
anything like this happening again I
will have both of you encased in cement
now get back to work you idiots now go
check out SCP Edition weirdest things on
Amazon Dr Bright's great idea and
hilarious list of things Dr bright is
not allowed to do for more wacky Antics
from the lovably deranged Dr bright